welcome to this video playing see dots
tov thatõs let us check this
international master christian tov
brazil brazil doesn't sound very
brazilian but ok let's see Queens gambit
ok I'll go do good I can play ok c 6 ok
let's let's do the the trade this guy is
taking its time ok I should try to play
quick this time maybe I can really do
something on the clock against him is
really slow check
yeah the Slovaks change a very
surprising recent yeah line that
recently quite surprisingly got into
fashion and it's never considered to be
a very critical but it has some attempt
has some ideas some poison so it got
popular recently let's let's see should
be four maybe or b-five in this
pollution I think this is a well known
position from modern practice but I
don't know exactly how they play it yeah
okay I have to do something about this
queen e to maybe probably have to move
the Queen anyway before sure before do
where do i go to be five yeah it seems
hard to believe that you go to d1 this
looks really wrong and to be one hmm
there's Roxy one huh okay
yeah i'm not going to to cover this this
pawn him if he's shaking twice I think
Bishop d6 might be good attending be
sure before and in general being
annoying on this diagonal you know where
that looks okay I think okay yeah that's
surprising if you take their you should
really grab the pot I think okay so
Bishop here right and then to before
okay this is not really something I had
expected yeah nevertheless it's it's
very much playable of course and 2-d two
or maybe I can always go to c5 yeah move
like a five it's not really a problem
that's difficult to to get anything
going in this position may be here three
traits i can play f3 and deform wait is
it better no no taking once before he
just recaptures and then two pieces are
hanging really a bad idea I interesting
is playing a pawn break himself huh but
I can take here take here yeah i'm not
sure if I want to take takes deep on
tanks okay let's not overthink it
maybe you can play with Bishop f5 here
or something like that yeah or this move
Mike I can play c3 wow this is not good
not good at all yeah this as well many
many problematic things happening here
okay I can let's let sacrifice this
exchange here the pawns here arm I mean
the pony is this is quite good avitus
got 84 he's got 94 not good I was that I
wanted to go Bishop f1 night f1 but he's
got 94 and this is really a huge problem
that's a huge problem and takes Queen
takes there is ok it didn't happen yeah
that's not great iam whatever you do
yeah maybe still not really good I don't
know it's simply not good this position
wow what a lousy game what a lousy game
yeah i'm just an exchange down yeah he's
playing this well
I cannot save it them there is no way to
save it
yeah I only played this bad bad badly
amazingly bad game yeah you care well I
saw that I lose the exchange but i
really thought i would get something but
this is like less than less than nothing
can I somehow stop the pawns at least I
is terribly slow what is he doing him
time warning around for your draw yeah
you will lose on time wow it's not
taking it
grah Harvard I am I mean I'm not
resigning here if you're playing so slow
and not that they're not taking it all
then well black for a fix on time yeah
I'm sorry I'm not resigning this but you
can accept the draw if you want I mean
it was really really really slow yeah
what a terrible game around here I think
white is just better but I totally miss
related I don't know what exactly went
wrong they played this well II five was
a good move really maybe it's maybe 92
is enter positional
92 this is really good yeah if the c5
was a strong resource I was thinking
that I saw Bishop f5 of course but I
wasn't a ab c 3 was even more of a
problem I was in general always thinking
that I can i get i get b 5 but it is
this is really really really bad yeah he
played this value was just terribly slow
not much to say I'm totally lost here
today well I just offered raw so let's
on the basis that position is lost but I
will win on time but if he doesn't take
it I'm not resigning this okay what's
what a bad game thanks for watching